.
MEANWHILE SMILEY IS IN A
STATISTICAL TIE WITH PATTY
MURRAY IN WASHINGTON.
THE CHIEF POLLSTER AT THE
TRAFALGAR GROUP JOINS US.
YOU BETTER BE RIGHT ON TUESDAY,
BECAUSE IF NOT, THEY MIGHT TAKE
IT BACK.
POLLING IS A HARD THING TO DO.
LET'S LOOK AT THE SENATE.
ROBERT, WE'LL GO THROUGH REAL
QUICK, BOTH OF YOU, AND WE'LL
START WITH GEORGIA.
ROBERT, WHO'S GOING TO WIN
GEORGIA IN THE SENATE?
>> HERSCHEL.
>> Sean: MATT?
>> I THINK IT COULD BE A RUNOFF,
BUT I THINK WALKER IS THE
FAVORITE EITHER WAY.
>> OKAY.
LET'S GO TO NORTH CAROLINA.
TED BUD.
MATT?
>> BUD.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, ROBERT?
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
>> Sean: BOLDUC IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
ROBERT?
>> BARELY, BUT BOLLED.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, MATT?
>> A TOSS-UP RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER, BUT
BOLDUC.
>> Sean: LET'S LOOK AT
PENNSYLVANIA AND Os.
MATT, WHO'S GOING TO WIN THAT
RACE?
>> WELL, BASED ON THE POLLING,
OZ SHOULD WIN, BUT PENNSYLVANIA
IS A WEIRD PLACE IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY COUNT THEIR BALLOTS AND THE
LIKE.
I HAVE TO HOLD MY BREATH AND SAY
IT'S A TOSS-UP.
>> Sean: WOW.
ROBERT, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK OZ GETS THE MOST
VOTES.
>> Sean: OH, BOY.
THAT'S A LOADED -- THAT'S A
LOADED TERM YOU JUST THREW OUT
THERE.
IN THE END, DO YOU THINK OZ WINS
THIS?
ROBERT.
>> I THINK WHETHER HE WINS IS
LIKE MATT SAID, IT'S A TOSS-UP.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S LOOK AT J.D. VANCE IN
OHIO.
THOUGHTS, ROBERT?
>> VANCE.
NOT CLOSE.
>> MATT?
>> YEAH.
SAME.
>> Sean: RON JOHNSON IN
WISCONSIN.
MATT?
>> YEAH.
HE'S GOT IT.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
ROBERT?
>> I THINK HE WINS, BUT BECAUSE
HE'S AN INCUMBENT HE MIGHT -- HE
MIGHT BE A LITTLE UNDER WHAT THE
POLLING SAYS.
>> Sean: OKAY.
NEVADA.
MATT?
>> THAT ONE I BELIEVE IS GOING
TO BE ONE OF THE TWO SEATS THAT
WILL PROBABLY CAUSE REPUBLICANS
TO SECURE THE SENATE.
I THINK HE WINS.
>> Sean: OKAY.
ROBERT, DO YOU AGREE?
>> DEFINITELY.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
ARIZONA, BLAKE MASTERS, ROBERT?
>> I FEEL MASTERS WITH THE
LIBERTARIAN GETTING OUT, HE HAS
AN ADVANTAGE NOW, AND HE'LL
CLOSE THE GAP.
I THINK HE WINS IT, BUT BY A
HAIR.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU THINK,
MATT?
>> I BASICALLY AGREE.
I THINK KARI LAKE IS RUNNING SO
STRONG THAT'S GOING TO HELP PUSH
HIM OVER THE EDGE.
>> Sean: LET'S LOOK AT THREE
GUBERNATORIAL RAISE.
NEW YORK, MICHIGAN, NEW YORK,
ARIZONA.
WHO WINS THOSE THREE RACES,
MATT?
>> KARI LAKE IS GOING TO WIN IN
ARIZONA BASED ON THE POLLING
WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR THE FOX
AFFILIATE THERE.
MICHIGAN WILL BE A TIGHT RACE TO
THE END.
I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO TALK ABOUT
NEW YORK, BECAUSE ROBERT IS THE
MAN WHO DISCOVERED THERE WAS A
CLOSE RACE THERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
I'LL TOSS THAT TO HIM.
>> Sean: YOU'RE PUNTING ON THAT
ONE.
I LOVE HOW YOU GUYS PUNT BACK
AND FORTH.
ROBERT, WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THE
THREE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I THINK KARI
LAKE IS -- IS THE NEW SUPERSTAR
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I THINK SHE'S GOING TO WIN.
SHE'S GOING TO IMPRESS PEOPLE BY
HOW WELL SHE WINS.
I THINK MICHIGAN IS A TOSS-UP.
IT'S MORE ABOUT WHAT THE TURNOUT
FOR OPPOSITION TO BALLOT
INITIATIVE 3 DOES.
THAT'S GOING TO DRIVE THAT RACE
MORE THAN ANY OTHER FACTOR.
NEW YORK, I THINK IT IS VERY,
VERY CLOSE, BUT COULD GO EITHER
WAY.
IT'S GOING TO BE ABOUT CRIME,
BUT IT'S JUST A MATTER OF --
IT'S GOING TO BE A TOSS-UP.
>> Sean: THANK YOU BOTH.
CONGRATULATIONS ALSO TO BOTH OF
YOU.
THE HIGHES